[Music]
[Applause]
Big Mike gock joining us he was on the
call last night with Westwood One
Cowboys and the Chargers and uh co-host
of Gojo and goic on DraftKings Network
former Mothership employee and uh friend
of the show Big Mike good to talk to you
buddy let me start with pregame yep
skirmish Donnie Brook altercation what
exactly happened prior to the game
between these two teams you know it's
one of those things that just little
kindling wood and then it it Flames a
bigger fire and I have to admit I was I
do my first hit on the field I like
going down there for pregame and I
actually had some flashback because I
was one of those knuckleheads that would
do something like that so I saw the
fight start and I started running over
and then I thought wait a minute I'm
going to get my ass kicked if I go over
there I better not get too close but you
know the Rams they were starting to to a
few a few of the players were over there
and that's right where the Cowboys run
on to the field and as they ran on of
course somebody says a couple words and
some people stop and then they're jwing
one another next thing you know they're
pushing one another and it never you
know just like most fights in the NFL
they don't they don't lead to anything
really bad but it got Chippy at the end
of the half uh at the field goal at the
end of the half they got it got a little
chippy again these these teams were were
playing you know both teams were playing
to stay within one of their respective
division leaders the headline from this
game should be about which team well I
think it'll be about Dallas so Dallas
got their butts kicked against San
Francisco right and I think the side of
the ball that really took it uh to heart
was the defense because we knew this
Dallas team was going to be led by their
defense and while they only had one sack
it was a Michael Parson's late sack they
had pre their pressure rate was like
47% uh it was great they were getting in
the face of her and moving them off as
Mark and I think they they really took
that personal to where they were
considered one of the upper echelon of
the NFC and then after that loss to San
Francisco people are now saying it's
it's San Fran it's Philly it's Detroit
you know and putting Dallas with Seattle
and dropping them down a rung and I
don't think they feel they belong there
unfortunately they're a little
inconsistent so that might be where they
are right now so I I think it was more
on them this Chargers team Dan they you
look at the talent they have and we just
see they they just kind of continue to
underachieve
I'm trying to figure that out because to
me I think the bigger picture is what's
going on with the Chargers Dallas is a
good team the Chargers should be a good
team yes Justin Herbert is not a good
fourth quarter quarterback and Brandon
Staley feels like he's coaching for his
job and we're you know six weeks into
the season so here's the interesting
thing too right is Staley's side of the
ball is defense and the defense has not
been good in the last couple of years
for the Chargers so that's been kind of
a surprising thing you a quarterback
that can air out some incredible stats
but they never seem to get it going
especially with the running game and now
Herbert had a good record now albe it a
small sampling size he was three and0
against top five pass defenses and I
think the Cowboys were either two or
three against the past and the Cowboys
had given up more passing yards from
week one to week five they had given up
more and more and more so I thought and
with Herbert's record against that they
could be had a little bit in the passing
game but you have to give a lot of
credit to the Cowboys defense they
stepped up in this and what I thought
was a weekend of great defensive
performances see the Jets and see the
Cleveland Browns and other teams as well
but this charger team has really been an
enigma to me uh Dan and you bring up a
great point of I want to see how many
hurries you have pressures you have how
many times you hit the quarterback
because you can have a guy get three
sacks and we go oh man they must have
got to a quarterback I don't care as
much about that as I do every single
play that you're bringing pressure
you're hitting him every single play
because after a while you know the sheer
accumulation of that is going to you
know you know it's going to bring down
Justin Herbert and confidence and you
know he's going to see people in the
pocket so um I thought that that was so
important that Dallas had heat on him
all night long yeah and and I mean it
took us until the second half to even
mention Michael Parson's name I I think
he was something was up with him because
his body language it was it was not good
I don't if he was under the weather or
what but to your point and your right
you look at the charger side of it they
had four sacks Morgan Fox had two of
those sacks but there wasn't that
pressure rate that Dallas had because it
doesn't always have to be a sack if you
can get a quarterback off his Mark but
these quarterbacks are a lot better
nowadays getting off their Mark and
making throws on the run but Herbert was
just off I mean he was throwing behind
he was he had a he had a Keenan Allen
had an out and up that was wide open
that would have been six and I couldn't
believe believe that Herbert overthrew
him the way he did when he was wide open
so your point is well taken just one
second it was late by Mah Parsons but
the constant pressure that has a
cumulative effect on a team where do the
Lions stand in the rankings with NFC
teams right now so I I would put them
third right now I I'd put them behind
San Francisco and Philadelphia and I'd
put Detroit right there and then and
then Dallas after that then you're
looking at like Seattle and the Rams in
another tier but I would put the the
Detroit there uh I I I love what's going
on just you know when me and Mike in our
show this morning we talked to lus Brown
who was in my draft class in 85 he was
number six overall such a great guy and
he spent his first 10 11 years in
Detroit and really lived the other side
of what's going on right now and he does
the radio for them now and just talks
about the difference and it starts with
Dan Campbell they always say you take on
the personality of your coach and and I
had said as former players I'm GNA tell
you when he Dan first had his first
presser and talked about biting kneecaps
and how tough they were going to be if
I'm if I was a current player on that
Detroit team I'd be going oh man
training camp is gonna be so hard you
know he's gonna hit us and everything
but they have bought in and when you buy
in and then see the wind you buy in even
more they're a tough team the offense
the last couple of years has put a lot
of points on the board the defense is
starting to step up so yeah I I have
them right there I mean and and they'll
they'll get a shot against you know some
of these top teams you know during the
season as well and their goal obviously
win the division which I thought they
could do and then let's see how far they
can go on the playoff but what a fun
team to root for now he's Mike gock
co-host of Gojo and gock on DraftKings
Network and uh I'm wondering about this
as I'm watching last night Mike McCarthy
doesn't
really I don't get Confidence from him
if I'm a Cowboy fan you know the what
happened at the end of the first half
game management penalties again the last
couple of years they're they're up there
you know it just feels like Groundhog's
Day with the Cowboys with Mike McCarthy
so the word I use and I used it last
night is inconsistency right you see the
talent that they have but you want to
see it on a more consistent level and
you're right about the penalties I mean
and it's not like the Chargers were
innocent either Dallas had 11 the
Chargers at night 20 penalties that the
game was just interrupted and choppy
because of that but there's no
consistency with this team listen you
you you have Tony Pard being the main
back the two games before this he didn't
touch the ball but eight nine 10 times
now they had a blowout win against New
England and a blowout loss against San
Francisco so the running game kind of
goes out the window but last night was a
good time to get it rolling again he
averaged two yards a carry I mean Dak
Prescott was the leading rusher thanks
to his 18 yard touchdown run which was a
nice ball fake on his part that's the
word I would use inconsistency with the
coach inconsistency with the quarterback
because Dak was off a bit but when he
was on man he was firing darts and he
was moving out of the pocket and running
well as well and when he does that and
that defense is on they can be one of
the better teams but they're in
consistencies and then shooting
themselves in the foot with penalties
clock management time those are all
things that you can kind of get away
with like they did last night in a game
but when you get to one and done in the
playoffs you know that's going to make
you be the done part of it do you think
that Robert Craft could fire Bill bich
no I I think it would be one of those
Mutual hey I don't want to fire you
that's not the way I want to go what do
we think here if push came to shove and
Bill bellich said I'm adamant about
staying I think craft would have him
stay uh so I don't think he would fire
him but I think if he wanted him gone
there would be a long conversation about
hey Bill you know do you step away I
want you to do it on your own I want you
you know I want it to look that way but
just flat out fire him I I I just don't
think so would he allow a GM to come in
well that's the question that is
absolutely the question because when
you're as successful as that listen even
if you're not as successful is that we
all think we're making the right
decisions and don't want to be demoted
in any kind of a way and that's exactly
what it would be but the days of the
head coach being the GM really I I are a
thing of the past there's just too much
to have to keep an eye and I think it's
more very difficult to do so that would
be something that maybe would happen and
I would think they they'd almost try and
keep it under wraps that it didn't
really happen but that is something I
think kind of like Jerry Jones when he
was making all the decisions and Stephen
started making the decisions one of the
one of the you know ones a while ago he
wanted Johnny Manzel and they were like
Jerry no let's take this guy named Zack
Marton who's a walk-in Hall of Famer you
know so you start to kind of shift the
power of decisionmaking and that's
something I think they could do but
everybody's got an ego you know and I
would imagine bill has a pretty good
size one as well and he has the Rings to
prove it so uh that might not go over
too well but that's certainly a thought
process that's something that maybe
should happen because they have not been
doing well from free agency to drafting
as of late if the Jets are playoff
eligible eight weeks from
now and Rogers is
close do you
risk uh listen it saying that a lot
depends too on how Zach Wilson is
playing let's say Zach is playing how we
think Zach is going to play good to get
playoff eligible exactly but Aaron
Rogers would be a much better uh
situation yeah you're taking a risk on
reinjury for sure but man how many shots
you get at the the Golden Goose right I
mean they they did what the Rams have
done what Tampa Bay has done you sell
your soul especially the Rams did to get
the title and the Rams got the title
they did that by signing people to cont
conts maybe they shouldn't have in Tampa
Bay but they got the title the Jets have
are doing this to get the title so man
you know damn everything you know throw
the guy in there I know you want him for
next year as well but you have that
defense right now and if he's close
enough where you don't don't think he's
going to reinjure you never know if
that's going to happen I I and as long
as Zach is is kind of the mediocre to a
little above mediocre for the rest of
the year I don't see why you wouldn't
give it a shot I don't think Dan I'll
say right now I don't think they any way
that Aaron Rogers would be ready to play
in the playoffs he's certainly given the
presentation that hey you give the
presentation all you want I mean you
know I mean you can say you can stand
there and throw a ball on the sidelines
because your Achilles is hurt your
shoulder risen so you can stand there
and throw the ball and I get modern
technology is getting better and better
I do understand that I would be so
hardpressed to think even in a quick
return that he would be ready to go I
just do not see it no matter what he
says
Aaron says a lot of things but why is he
doing it I mean is it for attention that
he's on the sidelines throwing the
football listen I think we all know
while I get along with Aaron I I believe
I know you get along with Aaron Aaron
does like the headlines right Aaron
Aaron likes to uh talk be seen doing
Football Talk Football Talk outside of
football like the little battle he's
getting in with Travis about the
vaccines he he believes he's a he is a
smart guy he believes he's a very smart
guy and he doesn't mind throwing it out
there as well but I also think he's a
guy that does like kind of being seen
out there so that's part of it and I
don't doubt that his presence there
helps a guy like Zack Wilson and helps
kind of you know being on the sideline
suggesting plays I do think that could
be a huge asset to the team is it good
that there's no great teams in the
NFL probably I mean we go through this a
lot right whether it's individual Sport
and Tiger Woods do we want to see tiger
dominated or do we want to see him get
beat you know do you want to see a
dynasty in football the Patriots you
want to see that go away or do you want
to see you know uh you know them them
carry on it's a great question I'm sure
if you're you know any kind of a Boston
fan you want to see anything like that
go on but other than that you'd ra and I
think we're getting that in college now
as well George's played a couple of
games where they look like number one
but other than that it looked like boy
you'd love that 12 team playoff this
year because there's more than a handful
of teams you could believe in to do that
so I'm one of those that likes a little
more parody unless of course I'm playing
then I want to be the D at one I know
you were at the Notre Dame USC game
feels like we're starting to get the
analyst who are coming out now and maybe
cooling on Caleb Michael penx Jr Drake
May uh shador Sanders you got to see
Caleb Williams any concerns about him
being the number one quarterback no no
no I I still think he's a number one guy
his escapability is incredible I mean
it's you think he's nailed back there
and he gets out and he moves on the run
the guy he had listen he had a bad game
he had USC had the game Notre Dame had
against Louisville right they just just
did not play well enough to win USC
didn't Notre Dame's defense played
extremely well because neither offense
in this USC Notre Dame game played well
it was Notre Dame's defense that was the
story of this game so you know while
Caleb had been playing better than last
year when he won the Heisman that's why
I thought he could be the next back
toback like Archie Griffin though penx
has taken over the betting favorite and
certainly after this game he will but no
I'm not gonna go on this one game and
say uh oh Caleb Williams isn't the
number one pick in the draft good to
visit with you my best of the family
thank you again Mike for getting up with
us you got a anytime buddy that's Mike
gock co-host of Gojo and gock on
DraftKings Network and uh he was on the
call Westwood One broadcast last night
Cowboys and the Chargers